[Music]
chongqi is on the verge of becoming the
next great marvel movie hero but his
comic book history spans almost 50 years
but who are the friendly faces who have
popped up to aid the master of kung fu
in his many battles these are shang
chi's biggest allies
when the kung fu craze hit the united
states in the early 1970s marvel
capitalized on the trend by purchasing
the comic book rights to sax romer's
character fu manchu and his cast of
supporting characters marvel chose to
create an original character to lead the
series and chongqi was born established
as the son of fu manchu shang chi was
trained in the art of kung fu for his
entire life unaware of his father's
villainy until he sent his son to
assassinate an mi6 agent named dr james
petry in 1973's special marvel edition
number 15. during chongqi's mission sir
dennis neal and smith confronted the
young martial artist and exposed the
truth that xiang chi's father was evil
as a genuinely good man chongqi joined
smith and the rest of mi6 in the war
against his father sir dennis neyland
smith and dr petry were both supporting
characters in saks romer's deeply
problematic and racist fu manchu novels
a xenophobic caricature fu manchu was
the quintessential personification of
yellow peril the racist american fear
that immigrants of asian descent would
eventually erase white culture in the
u.s in the novels this was the villain's
goal and dennis smith was the white
protagonist who fought him marvel
eventually lost the rights to romer's
creation and likely due to the deeply
racist nature of romer series they
haven't attempted to get them back thus
fu manchu was renamed zhengzhu and
dennis has simply been referred to as
smith ever since
shangshi's journey through the ranks of
mi6 was not a simple one after smith
revealed his father's true nature
chongqi visited his mother in america to
find out if it was all true after his
mother confirmed the news shanxi broke
into his father's new york city compound
and declared that he would not stop
until he had ended his father's dreams
of conquest chiang chi wouldn't
encounter mi6 again until sir dennis
neal and smith decided to send one of
his best agents jack tarr to apprehend
the young martial arts master and master
of kung fu number 17. nicknamed
blackjack tar was a veteran of the
british army when he was recruited by
mi6 to serve in hong kong and later
joined smith's fight against his
archenemy with years of experience and a
wealth of combat training under his belt
tar was a natural choice for smith's
team though the pair fought when they
first met tar and the young martial arts
master would soon develop a solid
friendship as blackjack proved himself
to be one of chongqi's most trusted
allies
of the many mi6 agents that xiangxi
worked with during the war against his
father's criminal empire sir clive
reston proved to be one of the most
dependable introduced and giant size
master of kung fu number three restin
would aid the young martial artist for
many years after they finally finished
dismantling zhang zhu's attempts to
conquer the world the pair worked
together to form freelance restorations
in master of kung fu number 95 a private
security firm established to combat
rampant corruption within the
intelligence agency they once served
though rights related issues kept the
creators from saying so outright the
all-new official handbook of the marvel
universe makes it clear that reston was
the descendant of two of the united
kingdom's most famous fictional
characters uber spy james bond and
master detective sherlock holmes the
writers implied that 07 was reston's
father from whom clive inherited a love
of terrible puns
don't say it
the writing's on the wall
mr holmes on the other hand was
supposedly his great uncle and the chief
reason why reston enjoyed smoking pipes
clive reston and chongqi's work at mi6
would soon be disrupted by the
introduction of their fellow agent laiko
wu in 1975's master of kung fu number 33
reston and wu used to be lovers before
laco left clive for another agent named
simon brettner who was secretly a double
agent codenamed mordillo laco discovered
his treachery and helped mi6 defeat
brettner whose loosening grip on sanity
led him to adopt the name death hand
after returning to mi6 lako began
working directly alongside both reston
and chongqi an assignment that soon
produced a great deal of tension as lako
and the young martial artist began to
fall in love after mi6 finally defeated
chongqi's villainous father however the
young martial artist decided to leave
the agency and retire to the quiet life
of a fisherman unwilling to leave her
role as a spy wu stayed behind and the
couple broke up in the years that
followed lako and reston would
eventually rekindle their old romance
and finally mary
early in his crime-fighting career
chongqi met another enemy he would
befriend years later introduced and
master of kung fu number 61 xiao sima
was a triad assassin who earned the
nickname skullcrusher thanks to his
deadly use of his signature weapons
steel balls bound to his wrists via long
chains hired to kill shang-chi the pair
would battle multiple times during the
master of kung fu series with chongqi
always emerging the victor their
relationship radically changed years
later in deadly hands of kung fu however
when chiang chi discovered that chao
sima and laiko wu had fallen in love
after leaving her estranged husband
reston leica was deployed by mi6 as an
undercover agent and skull crusher's
triad clan wu worked closely with sema
and inspired a change of heart within
him unfortunately the couple's love
proved short-lived as lako was
eventually discovered and killed by the
white dragon vowing revenge skull
crusher asked chongqi for help knowing
of the hero's love for laiko although
initially distrustful chongqi eventually
agreed to help the former villain
confront and defeat the white dragon in
a bizarre series of events however skull
crusher ultimately sacrificed both
himself and the white dragon in a ritual
that resurrected lake o wu allowing him
one last kiss from his beloved before he
departed for the afterlife
[Music]
hey everyone throughout his career
xiangxi has worked with many of marvel's
heroes but perhaps his single greatest
super-heroic friendship lies with none
other than spider-man himself the two
heroes first met in 1974's giant-size
spider-man number two when chongqi's
father tricks the two crime fighters
into a deadly battle both convinced that
the other is a murderous villain the
heroes fought to a standstill until
spider-man finally realized they've been
duped united at last the pair teamed up
to stop zhang zhu and send the villain
packing once again this adventure was
but the first of many meetings between
the two heroes kicking off a friendship
that continues to this day during the
daredevil focused shadowlands event
chongqi helped peter keep mr negative
from expanding his criminal empire later
during 2011's spider island event a
virus began granting people across
manhattan the same powers and abilities
of spider-man including chongqi at one
point in the storyline spider-man was
robbed of his sixth sense meaning his
fighting abilities took a drastic turn
for the worse luckily as early as
amazing spider-man number 666 chang-chi
had been training his old friend in the
way of martial arts working together the
two heroes had developed a new fighting
style they called the way of the spider
which later helped peter to regain his
spider sense for good subsequently an
amazing spider-man number 672 peter
released a device that destroyed the
spider sense of every infected person on
the island trained for a decade in the
mythical city of kunlun danny rand
seized the heart of a dragon to become
the immortal iron fist illegally
experimented on by a mad scientist while
imprisoned for a crime he didn't commit
carl lucas used his newfound super
strength and unbreakable skin to
reinvent himself as luke cage together
they are the heroes for hire one of the
only super powered private detective
agencies in the world as marvel's two
premier martial arts heroes it's no
surprise that chongqi is often paired up
with iron fist the two first met in
1976's master of kung fu annual number
one when daniel enlisted shang chi's
help to rescue colleen wing the two
teamed up again in deadly hands of kung
fu number 29 in which a villain
attempted to force the two martial arts
masters to fight to the death hired to
retrieve a statue from the lawless city
of madrapur the heroes for hire
recruited colleen wing wolverine shen
quay and chongqi in 1998's heroes for
hire number 18. together they
successfully retrieved the statue and
foiled a warlord's attempt to conquer
china though the private detective
agency would disband after they returned
to the u.s despite this adventure chi
wouldn't actually meet luke cage until
years later in 2006's black panther
number 11 when the young martial arts
master and luke cage helped save
t'challa from an arranged marriage to
one of shang chi's siblings
when his solo comic book series finally
ended with issue number 125 in 1983
chongqi began a long era in which his
only appearances consisted of cameos and
brief stints on super-powered teams
after working with the heroes for hire
shang-chi found his next superhero team
alongside daredevil though initially a
simple branding initiative featuring
marvel's more street-level superheroes
and adult-oriented stories marvel
knights eventually received its own
self-titled ongoing series it featured a
team of heroes brought together by
daredevil
in order to finally deal with the
murderous vigilante known as the
punisher formed in 2000's marvel knights
number one the initial team included
chongqi black widow and dagger though
other heroes would later join or aid the
team and although daredevil's team never
received an official name they continued
to work together until the series end
fighting a number of other threats even
after they finished with the punisher
shang chi found his next team in the
avengers earth's mightiest heroes though
it took a couple of tries to get there
avengers
his first encounter with the team took
place in 2010's secret avengers series
when steve rogers covert ops branch of
the avengers discovered that a group of
villains known as the shadow council
were attempting to resurrect chongqi's
villainous father the former captain
america asked the master of kung fu for
help in defeating them roger's team of
secret avengers included sharon carter
the beast ant-man the black widow
valkyrie moon knight and war machine and
together they helped shangxi discover
that his father's real identity is zheng
zhu a powerful and immortal sorcerer the
avengers ultimately defeated the shadow
council and ensured that jung zhu could
not be resurrected chiang chi officially
joined the main avengers team in 2013's
avengers number one feeling the need to
reform the avengers bigger and better
than ever captain america and iron man
recruited a large team of heroes that
included shanxi among its many members
outfitted by tony stark with high-tech
versions of traditional chinese weaponry
the martial arts master would help the
avengers defeat such threats as the
garden as well as both the builders and
thanos during the 2013 event infinity
when a group of aliens attempted to
kidnap the people of earth to create
feeding colonies in totally awesome hulk
number 16 fbi agent jimmy wu shield
agent jake o ms marvel amadeus cho silk
and chongqi joined forces to protect
them after they defeated the aliens the
six heroes decided to stay together as a
team and officially adopted the name the
protectors then after the dark elf
malekith invaded earth during the 2019
war of the realms event jimmy wu
convinced several of his protectors
teammates to join the agents of atlas
formed in war of the realms the new
agents of atlas number one through four
the agents were a team of heroes who
worked for the atlas foundation a secret
society based in asia that wu inherited
and decided to use for the good of
mankind the team quickly received their
own self-titled mini-series that ended
in 2020 with agents of atlas number five
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel comics are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]